gang that stay trashy tour is coming
into the home stretch baby grab some
ticket and come out and see the boys
little standup comedy plus we play a
little ay with the crowd it's a good
good time yeah uh in November we're
coming to Pontiac Michigan then four
shows in Chicago Illinois limited
tickets remaining for them get those
baby then we're hitting Minneapolis
Madison Milwaukee Sacramento San
Francisco San Jose Washington DC then
we're eding it in Philadelphia two huge
shows at the Filmore get those tickets
that's going to sell out we love you
gang yeah welcome to another another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
new favorite podcast this is Ru garbage
oh yeah it's little show we sit down
with your favorite comedians and we find
that if they gr it to be classy or just
a big old piece of trash [__] I'm your
host a try coming at you on a beautiful
day we're out back here at toies in the
new edition just saw her knock down a
half a bottle of Nyquil okay so dinner's
going to be a little late tonight boys
all right all right my co-host is coming
at you from right next to me really
sticking to me with the toties lately no
no no no don't [__] working on that for
two weeks don't put that on me he is the
CEO of Ru garbage he is international
businessman he's my best pal in the
whole wide world give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan everybody what up gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate you subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are TR to cooking baby
then obviously the greatest website of
all time
www.patreon.com you garbage gang it's a
goddamn party over there yes sir and how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
the twos the threes and the fours he
crosses the te's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone McGruff ands Toby
McMullen everybody what up boys hey pal
yo this guy we got in here get him to a
roulette table the kids got a hot hair
kids on a heater of a heater this year
scorching up the Earth Gang the long
hair ain't lying cuz we could be more
excited to have our incredibly and I
mean incredibly special guest here with
us today for the first time he is a very
funny standup comedian who was on a
meteoric rise right now youve seen him
just about everywhere you seen him on a
Tonight Show with Jimmy found he's on
tour right now and he has a brand new
Netflix special out right now called
cowabanga give it up for Ralph Barbosa
everybody there he is [__] kids D you
guys you guys have such great podcast
voice talk real fast you like this guy
was throwing up the like
ww.com I was like oh [__] hit him with
the weather and the traffic real quick
keep it moving baby buddy thanks for
coming in congratulations thank you
thanks for having me you're [__]
blowing up man I do all
right that's all right give us the
backstory where'd you grow up tell us
the whole deal Texas right Texas I grew
grew up um in Dallas Texas we're
actually a suburb of Dallas called
mosquite Texas okay yeah I was like one
block away from the Dallas city limit so
growing up I wasn't even like allowed to
claim Dallas by by actual Dallas
residents now now they claim me
now got the hot hand like yo Ralph we
always loved Ralph but now I'm like no
no no I'm
from in Downtown Dallas yeah I I hear
Staten Island out here in New York it's
a lot of crap and I feel like SK is kind
of like the Staten Island of sure yeah
Staten Island catches a lot of [__] from
everybody else yeah so yeah that's
that's where I'm from out in Dallas
mosquite whatever um classic Suburban
upbringing yeah um it's it's the kind of
place where like all my Hispanic
relatives who like lived in the hood
didn't respect me they're like nah bro
you live in a good neighborhood but then
like all all the people that I went to
school with that lived in like real
suburbs like if I told the white guy
from mosqu they're just like
ew God damn you're from the hood yeah
there's no winning
man stuck in purgatory what was uh you
grew up with your uh mom dad brothers
sisters what was the actually grew up
with my grandparents okay um yeah um you
know it's it's wild man because like
when parents get divorced they always
tell the kid like yo it's not your fault
it's not your fault but I don't know
like my I feel like it might have been
my fault yeah my dad left me with my mom
my mom left me with my grandparents and
eventually my grandpa left me with my
grandma like damn I'm the common
denominator Jesus Christ trying to get
the [__] away from you kids with Bad
Seed so me and my grandma we real close
you know yeah yeah for now yeah yeah who
knows what happens any brothers or
sisters yeah I got like a ton of half
siblings man I don't call them my half
siblings not to their face just in
public on public I don't know this dude
just on podcast um yeah I got a so I got
a sister in Mexico mhm that my dad had
with a a Mexican lady um and then I have
my teenage brother and sister who I
currently live with now I live with my
dad okay so like my dad my stepmom
actually they just had another baby so I
got like a tiny baby sister and then
with on my mom's side my mom has one
other daughter I got she's a she's a
pre-teen how old how old are you now I I
turned 27 today actually I wanted I
wanted to spend it with you guys thank
you happy birthday we didn't get you but
that's all right take anything you want
out of the studio you take that peanut
butter jar back there he's already got
his eyes on it this [__] got
peanut butter God damn guy's got some
peanut butter uh okay so so there's a
27y year age difference between you and
your youngest sibling MH damn where
dides your mom and dad go so you said
your your dad left you with your mom did
he stay in town or they just got a
divorce or did he Dip N they weren't
they were never married um but they were
living together at a certain point they
were uh they had me as like teenagers
okay and they were living together and
then they split up and then when I was
maybe like five um my dad was on
probation and he like uh for reasons I I
won't get into don't fair enough he like
uh he like beat the [__] out some guy
and he thought he was going to go to
jail so he just like took off damn and
then he came back he got like a lawyer
and he only did like two weeks in jail
so it wasn't your fault yeah nah that
guy had a comment some guy running his
mouth but nah my mom my mom was just uh
like just young like wild she was just
out there like doing her thing you know
yeah teenager you know what I mean yeah
and so yeah she just I don't know was
out there I don't know where she went I
was I never really asked damn but
sometimes she would come live with us we
live cuz I always it was I always stayed
with my grandma they were always in
mosquite your grandparents mhm okay
gotcha yeah and so no matter what though
I always stayed with my grandma and
sometimes my Mom would come live with us
and I would be like look who comes
running back to
us it ain't so great out there huh is it
mom even when I was like 23 and she was
still like come live with us like she
like stayed with us at that point I
always reminded her like me and me and
Grandma let you stay with us yeah yeah
yeah this ain't your house we're waiting
for you to get back on your feet did she
have a room when she would come home or
is she on the couch or the b n she had a
room she always had a room okay huh and
what grandma do for a living growing up
was she working nah no not my my
uncle uh made my grandma like retired
when he was like 15 or 16 he used to
sell drugs damn okay yeah okay so this
is shaping up welcome to the show I
think we've made our
decision the best pro sh and your 15E
Old Uncle makes his grandma or makes
your mom retire godamn okay must have
been doing good so that was what's was
fun the the lifestyle yeah so um back
then that street that we lived on in
mosqu was
like I mean that that area was like
pretty nice now now it's like kind of
going downhill but we were like uh the
first like people of color to move into
that block and then oh I think actually
my neighbor from across the street was
the first person of color but yeah other
than that it was like an all white
neighborhood my uncle
uh as a as a as a teenager was making
like really good money and he got my uh
when my mom was pregnant he convinced
like my my mom their mom my grandma my
grandpa and everybody to like let him
find a realtor and like move them out of
oh damn yeah they were living like on
the on the East part of uh of Dallas
okay and it was like really really bad
there it was like really dangerous and
yeah he got them to move like two days
before I was born and uh that like I'm
telling you that area was like pretty
nice at that time and uh yeah he when he
but I think by the time he got them
removed he was already like 18 but when
he was like 15 or 16 my grandma was uh
working like at like at a restaurant or
something and he just was like nah you
shouldn't work anymore damn damn 15 16
making [__] moves yeah that's all
right setting up 401K I can't even do
that now and I'm pushing 40 Jesus Christ
even if I could I would
never you can come stay with me get on
your feet but that's about
it I will charge you R damn and you're
still living with your grandom now no
actually I live with my dad now for the
first time ever I've been living with my
dad I've been there like a year now okay
yeah we moved out to this little uh well
my dad always uh he lived out there for
way longer than I did but we moved out
to a little land like an hour south of
Dallas damn so you're out there I'm out
in the country that's why I got this
Bass Pro Shop shirt I still haven't gone
fishing but I'm going
to yeah he some I'll be out there fing
the gear what's your pop do now uh he he
like remodels houses and does a lot of
like construction type work for okay
like contractor type jobs gotcha okay so
growing up at your Grandmom's um what
was school like oh easy I was very
spoiled too really yeah um my grandma
you know she had like free time and she
like spoiled me I remember when like
Spider-Man 2 or three came out I I
convinced her to like take me out of
school early so I could go watch it
during the day yeah my grandma my
grandma was the best and school was
pretty easy um I used to think and I
mean I still kind of do think that I was
very lucky to go to like a pretty
diverse school I feel like we had a
little bit of everybody uhhuh but then I
came to like New York and like this is
real diversity yeah my my school is just
like black white Mexican like here is
like Yugoslavian yeah everything there's
a little flavor from everywhere
yugavi I never met no
yugoslavians
huh okay and uh what was the high school
mascot growing up uh stallion that's
pretty goody Texas that's a real Texas
[__] good football team no really we
had the out of all the mosquit high
schools I think we had the coolest like
mascot like were the stallions the other
ones were like the Pirates the mosquite
skers what that's and it was just like a
really angry scrawny mosquito like buz
yeah um yeah I don't remember what the
other one was but that was like about it
the mosquite lantern flies coming into
town the
larvas but yeah we had the stallions and
we were so sorry and how'd you do in
school I was I was pretty good I was I
was I'll be honest I was really lazy
okay I did enough to like get by um if I
worked pretty hard and I tried I could
get like some straight A would your
grandma stay on top of you with your
your schooling and stuff like that was
she tough with you on that no nah nah
she was just she was pretty chill yeah
she she would she I don't even think she
knew what my grades were she knew they
were good and she knew enough to go brag
to the other grandma's like oh no he's
so smart you know like he's such a
talent but but I did all right were you
getting in trouble at all and you know I
got into a little trouble here and there
um I would do some something like crazy
every now and then nothing too bad and I
just hope that I wouldn't never get
caught you know I one time we broke into
a house that was pretty that got pry one
time we robbed the bank you know nothing
crazy that was probably the worst thing
I ever did it got it got pretty scary uh
cuz we we heard people like arriving
while we were in there we didn't steal
anything Christ we we man I was so it
was just so dumb we were like 13 or 14
and we broke into one of my neighbors
house who like lives on my blog and
because we thought that their older
sister had like weed or something I
don't I know why I used to I didn't know
how much weed went for I used to think
maybe if I just had a handful of it I
could get rich off of it like I had just
got done watching that movie Blow yeah I
got a dime bag selling for 14 Grand if
anybody wants it and so we we got it to
my neighbor's house and uh I was looking
for it and one of my buddies there was
like four of us five of us and one of my
buddies was like Ralph he's like come to
the kitchen and I went over there and
like I said we weren't like poor but I
don't we just never I guess picked up
these kind of snacks they had Nutella I
had never seen Nutella that's so we've
been talking about Nutella every episode
the past like five weeks so all right so
at 13 forget about the weed take the
Nutella Nutella we're all going to be
rich shit's imported so we're just like
hanging out in their kitchen like eating
these Nutella snack packs what the snack
pack just like having a childhood you
know yeah just
hanging and then we start opening up
their Christmas presents and [__] we
heard the door they had like a deadlock
mhm and we had already locked that
deadlock just in case somebody got home
and smart and uh yeah we heard them
coming in and so we just like ran and we
went to my other neighbor's house who
lived like across the street from that
house and just stayed there like all day
scared to come out just watching the
house to see if cops were going to show
up and they never called the cops and
you knew the family and they knew you
and stuff like that right no no no no we
knew like the like the the yeah like the
kids I guess and even even then we kind
of knew them we were like kind of mean
to them even if they would have made
that 911 call like what was taken from
the house well bunch of Rich crackers
are gone some snack packs in the tell
wait just thought raccoons broke
in they took all the Capri Suns damn
that's [__] funny H all right what
you do how'd you do on the SAT you take
the SATs I don't I don't think I took
those and if I did not very
well did you go to college at all I went
to Community College for uh I went to
community college and then I went to
like trade school okay yeah I I I got
I'm a I'm a certified painter all right
yeah go paint cars uh and I'm also a
licensed Barber which actually both of
those certificates are expired by now
but but I got them that's pretty sweet
man yeah that's all right expired Barber
any vacations growing up would you guys
go anywhere yeah we I mean and who was
the N like who was around when you were
a kid it was you and your grandmother um
your uncle was around I assume yeah my
my older cousin Carlos he's like two
years older than me okay very
overprotective but also the guy who kick
my ass all the time you okay like if
anybody kicks your ass it's going to be
me um I was very close with my buddies
growing up buddy haime we used to call
him haime and then in turn we' call him
hiney uh he's actually like the guy who
takes pictures and videos of like the
tour stuff we do now ni that's great
yeah his family was around my buddy Tony
buddy Daniel Mark just like everybody
who lived on that block we were very
close uh when we go to I guess
technically vacation we weren't going to
any like very touristic destination
spots but we're going to like visit
family in Mexico every year okay and so
my grandma would get all my cousins
together so we drive to like every city
that we had relatives in and then by the
end of the trip we had like five of my
cousins with me and just picking up
people along the way yeah yeah uh my
Grandma had a house in Mexico what she
still does I think and yeah we we spend
most of the summer there and it was
awesome she' take us to like the beach
the movies she had this pickup truck and
in uh one of the Cities we go to there
was a lot of like prostitution and a lot
of those I don't know if they have them
up here they got them like in Texas too
they're like these ders yeah we got
hookers they got these like drive-thru
liquor stores where like women in
bikinis come and sell you like the
that's all right and um well they got a
lot of those in the in the city we' go
to a lot of prostitutes and sometimes
after the movies my grandma would get us
all in the back of the pickup truck cuz
in Mexico they don't care if you ride in
like like the where the cargo and we
just drive around and she let us like
yell at
prostitutes we just yell like yame like
call me
like in boys we're going to go talk [__]
yeah we're like what's up baby like the
ladies were just like what my grandma
would just drive off bunch of kids
eating the TA in the back of a truck so
you had your passport young uh we you
didn't eat a you didn't need a passport
back then really yeah I don't I don't
remember when that came into if you're
under 18 I I think or 16 I I don't think
you need one even now do you have your
passport now now I do yeah I went to
Canada that's why I got it for work like
for comedy yeah so okay huh and what age
did you get it very recently yeah I just
got it like this year in fact when we
when we booked the Canada gig um it was
like a couple months I like I I found
out that it was a couple months you know
coming up upad and then I went and like
expedited the whole passport thing yeah
and I got it Canada's pretty cool you
know it's like Mexico but with white
people instead of Mexicans they're all
on the back of pickup truck [__]
hookers call me
a k let's talk about beam I'm beaming
baby gang if you're having trouble
falling asleep quit counting sheep and
get over to beam it's a hot chocolate
that knocks you the [__] out let's go
wake up like
Debo three days later you might not have
your chain on you but you're going to
feel rested and refreshed yeah uh it's
fantastic they sent it to us we got the
whole gang on it you mix um a scoop of
it with hot water or milk Stir It Up
Wait for the magic to happen with Nano
CBD and all natural ingredients will
have you they'll have you in sheepy town
in no time uh today Ru garbage listeners
get a special discount on beam's dream
powder it's their bestselling healthy
hot cocoa for sleep with no added sugar
now available in delicious flavors like
sea salt caramel cinnamon cocoa
chocolate peanut butter better sleep has
never tasted better better a recent
clinical study revealed dream helped 93%
of users wake up feeling more refreshed
and 93% reported that dream helped them
get a more restful night's sleep if you
want to try beam's best-selling dream
powder take advantage of their biggest
sale of the year and get up to 50% off
baby 50% off for a limited time when you
go to when you go to shop beam.com
garbage and use the code cyber at
checkout that shop beam.com garbage and
use the code cyber for up to 50% off
doing up back to the show back to the
show how's your grandmother in the
kitchen good cook yeah she doesn't cook
much these days you know she's she's
she's retiring sure cooking life but
yeah she used to make good uh called
albondigas they're just like this kind
of a stew with meatballs okay uh great
meatballs great uh flow tortillas
homemade flow tortillas nice great beans
you know would you guys do like dinner
on Sunday was that like a routine was
there any type of n schedule like that
the only time we had like some sort of
dinner schedule was when my grandpa's
still living with us uh he worked like
in construction type he did like a lot
of sheetrock mhm um he'd get home like
at the same time every day and so she'd
have like dinner ready and we'd eat in
the kitchen we had this tiny little
television with like the little VHS Port
thing on top of the fridge and we just
like watch TV like have dinner and watch
TV yeah CW or like tundo or something
you know did you have a TV in your room
mhm that same TV we had like another
version of that one
like I love TV TV was my best friend
yeah what was your what was your
favorite show growing up uh man I had a
few I I loved watching movies like I'd
always catch movies like on like um TNT
or TBS or whatever yeah also you guys
had cable mhm HBO all that stuff the
whole deal no no I had like like 99
channels okay so I watch like movies on
like VH1 CMT sure sure I was watching
like roadh house you know yeah shout out
to Road the double Deuce man shout out
to CF man they'll put a couple bangers
on every once in a while yeah yeah I was
watching like my cousin Vinnie Risky
Business it's awesome watching like
Spike TV a lot watching the slam ball
championships were you bringing your
lunch to school or did you buy it at
school n no we had free lunch that's why
we we lived like we were living like a
really easy luxurious lifestyle but as
far as the school knew my mom made
minimum
wage got to cook the books sandwich I
was the only I was the only kid in
school wearing like nice polo shirts and
like Nikes Jordans but also getting like
free lunch that's awesome man what the
[__] it's funny huh yeah I don't know
did you drink milk with dinner growing
up with dinner yeah no no no favorite
cereal as a kid probably tricks tricks
for kids were you allowed to have sugar
cereal whenever you want it yeah I
actually was diagnosed with type 1
diabetes at a young age damn so yeah it
was like too much cere yeah a little too
much much cereal there Jesus
huh what was the family car growing up H
I feel like you just marked off the
question like are are you
diabetic they have all your toes family
car whatever my uncle was in driving
anymore he just got passed it to your
grandparents yeah your unle sounds all
right we had like a we had like a blue
Escalade or black
BMW blue Escalade that screams drug
dealer we had had like a Mustang
damn yeah your grandom driving around in
a Mustang dropping you off at school
it's got Lamborghini doors on it you're
going to get free lunch my my grandpa uh
he always had like his work truck and
then he always had like his like going
out truck MH and so at first it was like
this uh 04 navy blue Chevy Silverado and
and he's like nobody touch it nobody
drives it but me always kept it under
tarp and then it it it became later on
he got this uh
red 2012 Chevy Silverado and yeah like
nobody could ever touch it like that was
his baby but the whole time we were like
bro nobody wants to touch it we were
literally driving my uncle's Corvette
right now yeah yeah you're in an
escalator I don't give a [__] about this
goddamn Silverado how many how many cars
were under a tarp in the in the in the
driveway just the one no no no so yeah
the only one that' be in the tarp was
the one that was in the garage was was
usually just my grandpa's truck okay
okay all right do you guys so in the
garage do you guys have a fridge in
there refrigerator mm- no no okay no
garage fridge no I wish you know what we
did end up having later was a garage
freezer which I didn't understand the
point of it what you keep what was in
there there's just like extra fish and
chicken and stuff like that okay my
grandma would buy so much fish and
chicken you'd think we'd have like a
family of
10 this is so wasteful oh you're
freezing it you're saving it for later
were you a Crystal Light family growing
up Crystal Light yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right sh sometimes not even Crystal
Light you're uh do they have great value
over here now store brand yeah great
value yeah yeah sometimes just oh great
value I think it said Great Valley no no
no great Val Great Value yeah I know
exactly what you're talking about it is
not of Great Value
but any injuries as a kid you break
anything oh yeah yeah um the first like
major one somewhat major I didn't break
anything on this one but it did tear off
like a ton of skin I got a huge scar on
my left ey um my Grandpa bought like
this mini little dirt bike thing had
like a lot of power and I tried to ride
it when I was like nine and it [__]
crashed nasty I did the same thing same
age yeah sweet hell yeah yeah other than
that I I broke my hand play fighting
with my friends I think it's called like
a boxers break where like the pinky
knuckle breaks off the rest of it yeah
so dirt bikes youd say a little mini
dirt bike couple of crazy cars and
anything like that in ATVs any jet skis
floating around the house uh my uncle
would like I don't think he ever owned
them but every now they took us to the
lake and they'd have like a jet ski like
they ran them and stuff okay but I don't
think he ever owned one we didn't live
near enough water water gotcha what was
uh what was the bike growing up the bike
yeah like the bicycle your bicycle
bicycle U man they get stolen all the
time it's probably your
uncle now it's just whatever they take
me like a Walmart or Toys R Us get like
a bike yeah okay rode with the biker
crew yeah you ever have power wheels
when you were a kid mm- oh like those
little electric cars yeah
um see you having one of those if I did
I I probably wasn't like big enough to
remember but I bet I did okay yeah I bet
I bet my childhood was amazing even the
parts I can't remember they keep the
butter on the counter at your grandma's
house or in the refrigerator
refrigerator refrigerator ketchup keep
that in the fridge or out um depends who
had it
last
were you allowed to eat in your room
hell yeah yeah I ate most of my meals
sounds pretty LAX up house I like it any
sports growing up I didn't I never
played for a team I was like too nervous
to like try out or go to practice but I
love playing basketball we we play
basketball like every day after school
MH but yeah I went to I went to my
middle school basketball tryouts and uh
I tried to like push the gym door open
there were so many kids in there they
were all like like whoever wasn't on the
court doing their try out time or
whatever was like leaning against the
wall and the doors and when I tried to
open it this big kid kind of like he
didn't even look back he just like
leaned back on the door to like reclose
it and I was just like all right that's
all right I don't have to try out it's
enough of that uh any jobs as a kid I
got my first job when I was 12 it was a
dishwasher at a Mexican seafood
restaurant all right yeah one of my
neighbors owned it by this time there's
a lot more Hispanics on the block by 12
you know sure and um yeah I did that I
would go work for my dad at his body
shop that's where I got into like
painting cars and stuff like sand cars
um I was a dishwasher at another
restaurant from time to time uh I also
did like my dad I had another business
where we would go like paint Apartments
like on the
inside uh stuff like that so good work I
think started working at 12 what was
your last job before you started popping
off in comedy I was a barber Barber
right okay huh would you work in a bar
barber shop or you just do it like on
the side yeah so at first I was only
doing it out of my room at my grandma's
and I had no plans on going to a shop or
even getting a license like I was I was
doing open mics every night and I was
making like two three hundred bucks a
week cut in hair at home whose hair were
you cutting just your your boys yeah
people from the neighborhood or whatever
and um
Grandmom's eventually uh when my
ex-girlfriend came out pregnant like
right when we broke up so I was like all
right I better you know get it together
here M so I I um I think by that time I
was going like on and off to Barber
College I went to this very ghetto
barber college where it was like on and
off to Barber College yeah it was like
if you if you paid this month you could
go but if you didn't like you couldn't
what was the name of it it's called Soul
Barber Academy oh my God bar Academy
that's awesome uh but yeah we makes it
sound like you live
there yes I'm at the Academy I had a
door
now but uh I went
so the down the street from the body
shop that my dad had there was this
barber shop we would go get our haircuts
in a in a neighborhood called Oak Cliff
and I ended up I'd always go get my
haircuts there even even when I wouldn't
be with my dad so later on once I was
you know about to be licensed that place
gave me like a chair and like oh nice an
official job or whatever what is that
process by the way how does that work do
you have pay the pay to rent the chair
yeah uh every Shop's different some of
them do like commission where you got to
give them like so many Bucks out of
every haircut but that place was Booth
rent so every every week I just paid 175
bucks a week to bad I don't think right
I mean how many it was all right as long
as you you're like stay busy that's like
nothing you know did you have a good
roster like people coming in oh yeah
yeah um you know since I had I started
cutting hair when I was 13 so I had a
long time to build [__] worker God
damn you still got CL like good Clippers
and [__] like that yeah hell yeah
um have you ever [__] someone ha oh so
many times when I started cutting hair
it was before YouTube tutorials were
like a thing just winging it yeah I just
had to like ask The Barbers at the shop
like Hey how do I do like this is and
that and try to memorize things they
said but by the time I'm there like I
don't know what I'm doing I just but I'm
trying [__] eventually I got the hang of
it you know holy how bad did you [__] up
somebody's hair oh bad man cuz my
friends got like Fades you know they
they' get like a like a ball fade where
you know you bald out the bottom and
just faded into the top uhhuh but to
start that you got to create what we I
don't what we call it like a Chili Bowl
okay where you do just one hard line and
then B out walking around yeah I don't
know I don't know why he does that that
whack ass haircut that's crazy I love
you but you're nuts he had to do it for
a movie and he likes it oh yeah is that
what it was yeah more power to you but
ah see that I just want to fade it so
bad get over yeah so that's like step
one of a haircut is that and then blend
that in yeah um so where would the
trouble come in blending it in
yeah I used to just sit there and try
things and I'm like maybe it's not bald
enough on the bottom we just make like a
harder
line did you have you ever uh get any
requests for any like for like stars
shaved in or like a yeah can you do any
of that [__] man I could do like minor
stuff I never really wanted to I I did
want to get into it for a while but then
it would take up time and I was like man
I just want to get on to the next cut
already like yeah it's not worth it I'm
I'm too slow at it to really make it
profitable I could charge like an extra
five 10 bucks but then my next guy who's
waiting it's like bro I got to go to
somebody else [__] this sure any lines
in the eyebrows when you were a kid nah
any piercings yeah uh but they would
always close on me I kept forgetting
that I had pierced my ears so I'd have
to like Pierce them like a few months
later
again I pierced my ears like four times
Jesus
Christ what uh
how old what was the young what age did
you start getting
tattoos uh man I was already
like I don't know 21 okay yeah it's
pretty good that ain't bad and what was
the first tattoo uh this crusty the
clown tattoo okay there we
go found what we were looking for G yeah
it's all right all right huh you said
you went to Community College for a
minute yeah what was the major theater
okay all right so then you kind of
started to realize that you wanted to be
an Entertainer yeah um I actually did
that before getting like the painting
certificate or anything like that I
wanted to I wanted to be a comedic actor
i' always wanted to be a comedian but I
thought I could be like in funny movies
or something you know big like Adam
Sandler wolf arol fan and um I had seen
online that Adam Sandler went to to NYU
for acting and I'm like well I guess
maybe that's like a start you know I
smart yeah yeah I I couldn't really get
into NYU but but Richland Community
College home of the Ducks uh I don't
know what their mascot is he got damn
Bradley Cooper down there they didn't
know what to do U but yeah I went but I
I didn't really do so well my acting
teacher one day was like H why are you
doing this damn not it wasn't like it
wasn't like super mean about it he was
just kind of like trying to get to know
me more but okay I think it was obvious
that I wasn't really like doing as good
as the other students and uh I told him
that I wanted to you know be a comedian
like be in funny movies or whatever and
he was like well that's cool he's like
you know just keep working at it but
he's like you should also Chase uh like
different Avenues of Comedy like do all
the angles or whatever and he told me
about like open mics I could do locally
there you go yeah and uh yeah I just I
fell in love with open mics and I didn't
I didn't even go back to like the acting
class I did the other stuff to like keep
a day job or whatever but the whole time
I was doing mics yeah but then you said
you girlfriend got pregnant yeah we had
we had like just split up and maybe we
had been split up for like 3 4 weeks and
um she was going to take a trip to
Mexico I was actually trying to like get
back with her and uh she had a trip she
was going to leave to Mexico for like a
month to visit like her dad or her dad's
land or something and um I was like
before you go like you should take a
pregnany test what if you're pregnant
and she was like that's dumb and then
like two hours later she called me
crying she like I'm pregnant no [__]
[__] yeah I was like yeah that's what
you get I was like [__] that's what I
get that's talk about the ultimate
backfire uh okay so you got a kid yeah
he's four now nice damn and where where
where's he at um he splits up time with
with his mom and and me nice um I'm I'm
usually home I'm usually back in Texas
like Monday Tuesday Wednesday sometimes
all the way to Thursday okay and so he's
with me those days from like Sunday
night to like Thursday morning great
take him to prek and all that the rest
of the weekend he'll be with his mom all
right there you go did he ask you what
are you whipping around in in Texas what
are you driving uh blue escalator n
right now I actually driving a 2018 uh
Infiniti Q Q50 Sport okay yeah and then
I'm I'm starting this actually been
draining my money I probably shouldn't
spend it this fast but I started a Chevy
collection so I just bought an 87 Monte
Carlo Luxury Sports what the [__] here
he goes I bought a uh a 95 single cab
Silverado
Z71 which are kind of hard to find sure
uh are they that your dad's house uh
couple of them are the other one I have
is a uh with 2,000 original miles like
in great condition looks like it just
came out the factory uh 1996 Chevy and
Pao Super Sport damn dude you are you
are so Texas man dude nor what guys like
I'm going to get one car you're like I'm
getting nine Chevys yeah this is his
[__] here's my Bun B
tattoo this is as new money as it gets
this is what we're talking about mind
you mind you I don't plan on leaving my
dad's house yeah you're living with your
dad that's crazy you he take the car out
if he wants on a weekend you might be
the only dude who has a car collection
and lives with his dad
yeah um all right so on that same tip I
don't know if there's other stuff but
when when the tour started going things
started popping were there any other
silly purchases that you made it's a
bunch of sneakers bunch of sneakers yeah
now now do you remember what the first
like the first big check was where you
were like oh [__] yeah the first big
check like the biggest check I this was
the biggest check I had at at the time
was um December of last year doing San
Diego La Factory and um I remember just
getting so cocky before I even got the
check I knew I knew how much it was you
going to be it's
1500 I just bought six cars no so I had
I hadn't bought no cars I was still
driving around like this beat up shitty
ass Honda like bad bad car uh was
probably going to kill me on the road
one day all right and we're in San Diego
me and my two buddies that that tour
with me and um I once I find out what
the check is going to be we're just
we're just going around restaurants and
stores and I'm like get whatever you
guys want man this [__] check is
going to be amazing like you guys want
shoes shoes on me [__] it like [__]
order yeah we're like eating steaks and
[__] but the check's not cash what are
you putting this on a credit card no no
no so I had a little bit of money from
like the previous gigs not not what this
check was going to be but just a little
change in my pocket you know but I'm
kids all right CH in my pocket my
pockets are are getting pretty close to
empty by Sunday You're blow you blew
your
a whole Bank two get of a time did the
boys take you up on the sneakers one of
them did yeah one of them didn't let me
buying sneakers until like way
later waiting for the good pair I
thought you were to be like one did he's
no longer
tour but anyway by the time you know the
weekend's done um I'm like waiting for
I'm I'm used to like the clubs now like
come somebody comes to get you and
they're like hey you ready handle up or
whatever and they were just like oh no
no we mail you a check like oh and I was
like oh [__] I was like why didn't I
think that you better mail it here [__]
cuz I'm [__]
waiting what what post office you
dropped that B I'm going to go pick it
up you know how embarrassing it was man
I had already like been everyone's
Decked Out sneakers jewelry Chris Ruth
bags and [__] I went back to my friends
like hey take those shoes off right
now N I just I I was such a that was
such a dumbass move because because this
is now like the you know for 2 and a
half months I've been doing pretty well
for myself you know making decent checks
or
whatever excuse me and now I'm going
back home like yo dad can I hold a
couple hundred
bucks hey young kid on the come up what
are you going to do did the mail come
today that's awesome that check came in
like a week and a half later I had to
pay back so many
people that's the worst dude when you
mismanage your money and you're like oh
I got this check coming you start
borrowing and then that check comes and
you're like I got to turn around and
give this all right back to people I
learned I learned my lesson yeah um do
you like to go out to have a nice dinner
every now and then but honestly man I
just like junk food I love Hot Wings
tacos Burgers okay where were you going
when you were out in San Diego like have
have you had anything since things have
started to work out have you had
anything that you never had before that
you tried uh n i stick to the same stuff
I mean when I do go for something more
expensive it'll probably be like seafood
also I love steaks I get like an
expensive steak and when I was in San
Diego uh we we walked to this basketball
court that's like just not too far away
and we're walking back to the to the
hotel or whatever um we there's like a
bunch of restaurants it's just like nice
Italian looking restaurant but we were
like in sweats and t-shirts or whatever
and I stopped to look at the menu that's
outside the restaurant and the uh I told
the L the the the receptionist lady or
whatever I was like can can you host the
hostess whatever they call him told the
secretary I might I'm a little hungry
and me my bullies might be looking to
eat oh man this kid's all
right hold my calls and give me a
Cesar I was like can we get a table for
three she was like yeah yeah she didn't
even sit us inside which was like I I
was I was I was coming down with a case
of like little man syndrome I started
getting offended she sat as outside in
the patio even though the inside was
like totally open it was all fancy in
there and then and then she uh she
didn't give us the menus she gave us the
menus for the specials and she and even
before she sat us she was like we have
lots of specials I was like yeah I
didn't ask about specials so when she
brought us the men for specials I was
like this son of a [__] so I asked when
I was like order like everything guys
yeah we're going to show her what's up
you know and she had no idea like that
what we even ordered she just went back
to the little uh Hostess Hostess then
Hostess
headquarters went back to the corporate
head list lady I got a check coming in
about two weeks you're going to be real
sorry sat me on a
patio yeah I just we just had like steak
uh
F how do you get your steak cooked
medium medium all right gentlemen I
respect it do me a favor send a bottle
of champagne to that secretary over
there tell to go collect some
[Laughter]
data oh man okay do you drink
occasionally yeah what what do you what
kind of drink will you have after you
know when you're at dinner or relaxing
or whatever I love beer okay uh I love
beer uh if I'm not drinking beer I'll
probably just drink whiskey I like
whiskey okay okay yeah all right what do
you guys like
drinking yeah beers beers whiskey yeah
nice too much uh at the house at your
dad's did you have you hooked it up with
anything like do you have a crazy TV in
your room oh yeah I got I got a great TV
I love TV like I said I love TV man I
bought love to see what his room bought
a TV before I bought better
clothes did you get a TV for the living
room too no that's my dad's
job that's [__] up dude you can't you
can't be making the kind of money you're
making roll find your own only yourself
a TV Dude the house stinks your bedroom
rules
a hot tub in there to be fair um it's
like coming to America when they redo
the one apartment nah to be fair my dad
uh he makes he makes really good money
got so that land that we live on he
bought a trailer home and that land when
he was like 20 okay and we used to go
and just stay there in the trailer home
when I go to stay weekend and stuff but
about
um i' say about a year ago now we uh he
finished building a like a pretty big
house on that property which is the
house we live in now so he had that
house like ready to go before I really
like right before I think really started
taking off for me so like there was no
need for me to like hook anything up he
all so you got the land you got the cars
out there you got the house yeah pool
pool at the house no pool we have a pond
but don't go in there it's pretty dirty
he giving us the warning don't go in
there you're ever down there my dad we
like shoot into the pond sometimes okay
like like Fourth of July and stuff nice
what kind of guns you got on the
property we got an AK-47
okay all right that's for I mean for
guys who live in New York City that's a
that's crazy yeah that's pretty crazy
also don't give me I I don't want people
thinking I'm like some super like don't
take my guns like sure I don't know you
can have them if you
want I'm not that attached to him yeah
but I just think I just do think it's
kind of like they're so easy to get down
there like how are you not going to you
know shoot into the pond every now and
then sure get you a gun Texas what the
[__] that's Texas Fishing baby yeah um
huh who's going to the grocery store
down there you do any grocery shopping
usually my stepmom okay uh sometimes
I'll go just when it when like um maybe
like on a Monday or Sunday afternoon
I'll take my son and we'll get like
whatever he's going to want for lunch I
got to like pack him his lunch and stuff
he's a spoiled kid man he wants me to
make him lunch and I just I don't know I
tell him all the time I'm like I can
make you sandwiches or send you with a
Lunchable he's just like do that he just
he's putting me to work yeah so I'll go
buy like snacks bikes or snacks that I
like and stuff like that yeah what do
you what what what what are the boys
like down there what are you dipping
into cuz you're young he's young yeah
I'm sure you still have a taste for for
the for the snacks I know I do I love uh
what is it like the UTS the cheese balls
okay man this is great my son Barrel
yeah get that Barrel we'll get some of
those maybe like I like uh hot chips
like hot funions Hot Cheetos stuff like
that does he eat that do you send him to
school with that nah he doesn't like
spicy stuff and what Lunchables do you
do you get him what does he like uh he
he likes like the the ham and cheese he
loves cheese like a lot what about the
cold pizza you guys mess with the cold
pizza at all man he wants that one but I
don't feel good him taking that one I'm
like like we got to draw a line
somewhere sure sure sure all right
yeah pizza that is all right um right
couple arue garbage questions here yeah
uh wait now they begin this is just the
background hey we just trying to get a
read on you you know how garbagey I feel
out yeah it's not
great you're down in the count
buddy oh man what's the bed in your in
your room king queen uh queen queen you
got a queen and you got a TV in there
got a TV yeah and do you eat in your
room now no no headboard it's just like
like a small wooden platform okay that
holds the bed is it pushed into the
corner of the room no it's in the middle
of the wall yeah come on I got some CL
baby just checking who knows you who
knows uh have you ever used axe body
spray mhm when I was when I was like 13
okay yeah you peeing in the shower yeah
from time to time if I feel it okay yeah
not going to like set a a a rule for
myself like no pee or I am definitely a
peer just I'll play it by year baby do
you brush your teeth in there not in the
shower not in the shower no all right I
would if I could remember to take the
toothbrush but and who's cutting the
hair now where do you get your haircut I
still go to the same barber shop Oak
Cliff Barbers that you used to work at
mhm nice mhm all all right there you go
um how many pillows you sleeping with um
you know what's crazy is like I just
about two but sometimes while I'm gone
like my younger sister or my stepmom
when they when they they do these like
clean the whole house days and they
clean up my room and then they leave
like more pillows okay sure so sometimes
I have two sometimes like six I don't
just just
depends man this setup sounds awesome
yeah uh what's on the walls and in the
bedroom now any posters good Fellas
Sopranos Scarface you know what's crazy
is um I I had an apartment for a little
while and I and even growing up in my
bedroom my my uncle uh huge Sopranos fan
sure and he had a he had a really really
good friend who gifted him when I was
like maybe 10 or 11 I don't know I have
he has a friend that gifted him a uh a
big Sopranos poster signed by the whole
cast damn like yeah has like this whole
certificate and [__] and uh my uncle
lived for my uncle had like nice house
like I said he always was doing good
something happened along the way that
for some reason for for like not even a
whole year he came to live with me and
my grandma mhm and I remember he just
like it was my mom's old bedroom and he
just like man made it look so nice yeah
before he moved in it looked like he had
like a construction crew in there just
like replaced the floors put like nice
hardwood floors and like wait really
that's F I swear to God just to stay
temporarily guys redoing the floors yeah
like the room was so
luxurious and he had that poster in
there and he had like nice furniture
like and when he left I remember he told
me he's like whatever I leave in that
room you can have like you can keep that
room like so I had I now had like the
nicest room in the house you riing up
the hardwood floors in your room um and
he left that poster in there so I'd take
that poster with me like anytime I had
like an apartment thing I didn't take it
to my dad's though cuz my uncle and my
dad don't like each other so I felt like
my uncle would probably get mad if if it
was hanging up in his house yeah because
the friend that gave it to um uh man he
rest in peace he's no longer with us so
now he's just like don't ever get rid of
that poster don't like don't let nothing
happen to that poster like yeah um so
it's just there at my Grandma's now in
my room I got like a a couple Funko Pops
the little the little bhe looking things
uh I do have a a little frame of like
the album cover and the CD of a Chief
Keef CD Like Chief Keef uh other than
that nah nothing really I keep them
pretty pretty plain pretty plain okay
dude a sign Sopranos of the whole cast
is a holy gra to a dirt bag I would kill
for that I think yeah I think is sweet
do you like mayonnaise I love mayonnaise
do you use uh helmond or do you use
Miracle Whip helman's mayonnaise
gentlemen all right when you the chicken
wings you get them well done N I just
get them how they come but I do get all
Flats you do yeah all right Gotta Give
them that all Flats how do you eat your
flat uh I don't know like my mouth my
hand no no no I'm saying do you uh who
the [__] this
guy no no no cuz CU you can you can just
eat it straight or do you pull one of
the bones out n I'll eat it straight
usually h i wait what do you mean pull
one of the bone you can like crack it in
half yeah you just crack it and then eat
it you can you can snap it and then one
of the slide one of the bones out and
then it's just like one bite you can get
the whole thing it's too I think the
wing is too small to give it that crab
leg treatment I
just I do love crab legs though yeah do
you like
oysters man I I I used to love them but
one day I ate like 14 of them and then I
got sick cuz it cuz it was like 14 but
like uh how old were you man this is
like like earlier this year but um like
every two oysters would be like a
different type of oyster yeah and I
think that's where I [__] up sure
crossbreeding them or whatever get
[__] jammed up with some food
poisoning oyers will open you up huh
have you done any nice dinner since
you've been in New
York um when I first met my agent and my
manager we went to like a pretty nice
restaurant or whatever MH now now I feel
like they know me better now we just get
like a burger yeah how do you get your
burger cooked uh medium do when you when
you're eating the burger do you put it
it back down upside down or do you keep
it flat you know I keep it upside down
why what question is
that that's crazy though cuz I never
thought anybody would ask me about that
I just noticed that I started doing that
too a gentleman's move do you cut the
burger in half or you keep it whole nah
I keep it whole okay fck [__] you're
going to sit here and my my new friend
Ralph like that [__] your problem all
right we got you on the turn it upside
down that's pretty classy in the past
365 days have you been to a hookah bar
nah okay
have you had a Hot Pocket in the last
365 days hell yeah okay how do you feel
about the rotisserie chicken food is
food I like it
okay you flying up front um Mo most of
the time yeah but I still only fly like
Southwest okay yeah I you're flying out
of Texas that makes sense will you buzz
the attendant nah never n take your
shoes off when you get on the plane yeah
you will yeah what about putting the
seat back will you drop the seat back uh
a bit okay yeah but you're conscious of
it yeah I didn't used to do none of that
stuff but after like the 50th flight
you're like you get a little used to
dude [__] off let me I'll take it off my
[__] shoes right I get it all right
there you
go uh
hotels um they don't got to be like
super great honestly I love a luxurious
hotel but I do get mad that they only
have like the more luxurious they get
the the harder it is to find an iron
okay yeah they just want to give you
like a steamer
this [__] Steamers suck do you know
how to iron you know how to iron iron
pretty good really yeah iron good enough
for me that's pretty good yeah do you
own any suits I own two Suits now okay
do you know actually I I accidentally
peed on one so now I just just I own a
suit in a half suit in half just really
drunk trying to take off my clothes and
pee at the same time well you just get a
dry clean you don't have to throw it out
I didn't want to touch the the peash
shirt really the peash shirt what are
the suits what are the brands
Hugo Boss really there you go Ralph
couple of hugos what was the reason for
buying them the first suit was because
uh it was it was my first tanro
appearance and I had always yeah I had
always had that goal in my mind I was
like I'm going go on there and I'm going
wear a suit my so my uncle uh like all
drug dealers eventually ended up going
to prison okay and I remember uh he was
like you know going through like trial
or whatever and on his final court date
he wore this gray suit with a a purple
Burberry tie damn and um I don't know I
I just thought it you know it sucks to
see your family go of course um and I at
that moment I was just thinking about
like all the good he had done for a lot
of my relatives like he took you know my
grandma out of a bad neighborhood he
retired her he he had like helped out
tons of our family in Mexico make sure
they had a roof over their head like
sure he did so much and then you know
now he's going to like pay for all the
bad things he did so when when I started
doing comedy
um I I would remember that suit and I
always wanted to do The Tonight Show so
I was like when I go on The Tonight Show
I want to wear that suit as like a I
don't know yeah like past the torch but
like in a good way now like I want my
uncle to know like hey I'll look out for
our family now wait did you wear that
exact suit like his suit yeah but I wore
sneakers with mine but not his exact
suit I I had it I just got it I wor his
tie he he did let me have that tie get
the [__] out of here that's [__]
awesome man that's [__] awesome dude
passing the Tor that's [__] cool as
[__] I was like that tie doesn't die in
court man it on The Tonight Show that's
got to see one more day baby yeah huh
how long is he in for uh he's actually
out now nuh-uh there you go yeah he's
cool he's like loving life he loves
Freedom um when he went in you hadn't
you weren't popping right no no no no no
even when he got
out but but now he's got to be ecstatic
oh man he's like and he got to see you
wear that tie on The Tonight Show yeah
yeah yeah that's sick that's [__]
sick that's a really good story that's
all right what are you doing deodorant
wise what do you like Old Spice yeah
yeah this one girl was like you wear Old
Spice like what are you a kid like it
smells good you didn't even know yeah
like what spice is not for kids yeah I
like also you're banging me like who are
you to judge yeah you got to get your
priority straight lady you're [__] up
worse than Old Spice any cologne
um man you know what's crazy is like I
I'll wear whatever colog like were were
ever gifted to me sure my younger sister
one day bought me this like Mercedes
cologne I don't even know Mercedes made
cologne she got it like out of Macy's or
something okay and it smells so good and
at first I just really like the smell
walking around smelling like new car and
then eventually the you know being on
the road here and there I'd get lucky
with a girl or two sure and they would
always compliment how I SM M so after
that I was like bro I'll stick it to
this that's it yeah that's the you're a
Mercedes man signature sent all right
that's all right huh bam I mean what a
tail yeah I'm got I think I think we got
enough dirt under the finger nails to
render a
decision I mean how do you get how do
you get your eggs cooked uh I usually do
scrambled but sometimes I'll do like
over easy over medium you like eggs
benedict I've never tried him really
yeah honestly I look at that I'm like
the [__] is that for do yourself a favor
try it good you'll love yeah it's all
right that's funny man I don't like
change I'm just like scramble my [__]
and take your paper straws with
[Laughter]
you huh you ever saved a Crown Royal bag
nah I've only had a bottle of Crown
Royal once when when I was like 21 or 22
my buddy worked at a very ghetto
Nightclub in Dallas he was a
photographer of the club and for my for
my birthday he's like's like oh the one
that I grew up washing dishes with at
his family's restaurant who's who's now
the photographer for us um dude you got
the [__] Squad with you awesome
that's [__] awesome yeah man he uh he
got us a section at this really ghetto
nightclub and they gave us a bottle of
Crown
Royal it's just like two guys hanging
out like chugging a bottle of Crown
Royal like we ended up just sharing
shots with whoever wanted a party guys
girls whatever look for somebody to hang
out with yeah and uh I I I drank like
half the bottle alone I was I was I was
hammered and I was so hung over the next
day it took me like a year to drink
Crown Royal ever again every time I
smell it I want to throw Soo I have that
cuz I drank half a bottle when I was in
like eighth grade anytime I smell it I
want to [__]
bombit
man anyone in your family ever involved
in a pyramid scheme yeah my grandma no
[__] yeah she would do like these like
the you know when they sell like those
vitamins and supplements that's the
first yes we've ever gotten on the show
to that question which is awesome
huh any time share pitches you ever go
to a time share pitch nah have you ever
waited to get someone's
autograph
um nah
I I don't know maybe like I'm a fan of a
lot of artists celebrities whatever uh
maybe because I never really run into a
whole lot of them and when I do run into
people I'm like a big fan of my my main
thing is like I never wanted to like
piss him off or anything yeah I kind of
just want to i' rather be like the fly
on the wall just so I kind of hear them
talk with her but when I met bum B I was
like can I get a picture shout out to
bum B every dude from Texas loves bun
yeah what was your first concert I've
never been to a live concert what what
never why that never crossed when I was
in high school um and my friends would
start going or like not my friends my
friends were as lame as I was but
buddies buddies from high school when
they start going um I never really would
have like the money to go once I was
like in high school that's when like the
the dream was over for like my family
people started getting locked up or
whatever got so um also I was I I was
getting older people were expecting me
to like provide for myself but I I
wasn't making a whole lot of money like
I'd work on weekends I'd make some chump
change and I just use it for food maybe
going to the movies or something um I
never would put any effort to like
finding out when an artist I like was
coming buying tickets to their concert I
also didn't want to like sit far I was
like I go I'm going to go up front but
by the time I was like 18 19 I started
going to open mics and like shows and
and that was all your time yeah I was
like I'll go I'll go to concert one day
but yeah I still haven't gone I I have I
know what it's like though I have seen
life performances like when I was on
Bird's tour sure uh jelly roll popped in
and played a song yeah so that was cool
and then when I did uh I did Mo am day
in Houston that's where I met bun Talib
qualed was also there so I got to watch
Bun B and Tal qual uh perform so that
was pretty there you go yeah that was
like 6 months ago probably no I was just
like a month
ago it's first concert 27 let's go yeah
yeah a man that's all right buddy I
[__] love you man that was uh that
was quite the [__] tail 100% garbage
you're trash sure dude I mean even at
your dad's house you got six cars I got
a call like we see it dude yeah I get
mad at my little brother when he touches
the cars don't even look at him
Gang Ladies and gentlemen Mr Ralph
Barbosa has an amazing special out right
now on Netflix called canga he's on tour
right now do yourself a favor check him
out absolutely hysterical anything else
you want the folks there to know uh
follow me on Instagram there you go RAF
Barbosa or
else Kibby what do you got for him uh
guys we're all over the road tickets are
moving quick shows are selling out get
them while they last rug garbage.com
gang we love you and we'll see you next
week peace